[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Omari Hardwick
and Rome Flynn who star in fantasy
football which is on Paramount plus
Friday how you guys doing today what's
up what's going on
how you doing good what's up with your
energy by the way yeah thank you
you just woke us up we're up oh hell
yeah good you got great energy yourself
for waking me up this is good so Omari
having played college football before
and having history with you know
football just in general in your career
was something was there any hesitation
to jumping in something that was so
familiar to you or did you all in right
away doing this film
um all in right away not from the
football aspect you know it's got to be
a white football film I think you set it
up uh well with the way you stated
coming from the history of football
Roman I just you know just stated on on
an interview prior that we're not
fantasy football guys you know guys like
us who've played the sport no matter the
level you
you honor it and you respect it and so
for me I'm equally honoring and
respecting playing or diving into your
point the right football field and me it
was the family aspect it was the fact
that uh
once we saw what was on page and it made
sense and then the cast
just phenomenally cast it uh shout outs
to our casting directors
um
you know and we really
we don't have to search high and low for
the places that the script needs us to
go if you come from sport you can pretty
much find that if that's the epicenter
of the film but it's really not I think
that's the backdrop of the film in my
opinion it's about people battling their
own you know whatever you got going on
in your life whether Rome is called the
antagonist antagonists or not he's
probably battling his own stuff
well I know he is and whether Bobby is
sort of the one that you end up rooting
for Bobby ends up I mean at some point
did you have issues with so
um I definitely think in terms of the
past life that I've had with football it
was the right football film to do but
I've definitely said no to football
films that weren't the right one so
shout outs uh uh Paramount plus and
Nickelodeon and Spring Hill and genius
because truly it started with them and
getting Richard T Jones and Anton and
and then you gave me an incredibly
gifted little bro in Rome um who's
forever my teammate
um which is cool to say he played my
teammate in this and now in real life he
is and you give me the whiz kid of them
all and that being Marseille and Kelly
Rowland the legend then We're Off to the
Races Tony Gonzalez the other Legend Who
brackets who puts it all together maybe
he's the glue of it all yeah hell yeah
and I like you saying all the layers
about this film and it being the right
football film not just doing it because
it's football so really good and
football fans and regular film fans are
gonna love this which is great and Rome
I'm gonna start you off with this
question because I really want to ask
you guys this but if you guys because
there is this video game effect in the
film with Madden if you guys are gonna
play each other Madden right now what
team are you taking and what difficulty
level are we playing on oh man
um you know I I would say we'll play on
rookie just because I don't know if it
really plays like that right right if
you want an electrifying high scoring
game we should play on record you know
what I mean yeah I would say that it's
as a toss-up I mean I like Patrick
Mahomes but I love playing with Lamar
Jackson I just feel like oh yeah on the
game he's a cheat code you know what I
mean and so what he can do with his legs
and also he can throw man he really can
throw and even on the game uh he's
really good you know uh so I think it'd
be it'll be cool I I win most definitely
but you know he would he would
definitely win but you know following
and following Rome's thought process
then I'm gonna go with the Bears because
what we are oh yeah why because what we
are seeing I think Rome would agree is
that the kid that was at University of
Georgia as you know who we didn't really
use a lot he could be mad at me but we
didn't really you know Kirby's my former
teammate we didn't really use him but I
think Rome would agree and coming from
Chicago Rome would appreciate this
Justin Fields is is proving to be he's
finding this groove and he's doing his
thing and so if the cheat code is Lamar
what Justin is showing with his legs man
I mean he's broken records yeah so I
play as the Bears let wrong play me out
as a rookie he probably stunned me a bit
but hopefully Justin Fields wouldn't
embarrass me too much yeah I love that
answer and I'd love to see that one day
you guys doing Lamar versus Justin
Fields it'd be amazing Omari and Rome
thank you guys so much for joining me
today everybody check him out and kill
it in fantasy football plus this Friday
I hope to talk to you guys in the future
thank you